POMPOSITY, GROUPTHINK.
SEAN HANNITY STANDBY FOR THE
9:00 HOUR.
>> Sean: YES, SIR.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY," BASIC
QUESTION.
CAN YOU NAME ONE GOOD THING THAT
JOE BIDEN HAS DONE AS PRESIDENT,
JUST ONE?
IN YOUR MIND, WHAT HAS HE DONE
FOR YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
HE REPEALED ALL OF TRUMP'S
BORDER POLICIES THAT WERE
WORKING.
AND WE HAVE ANOTHER INVESTIGATE
A REPORT TONIGHT.
HE PROMISED TO ERADICATE
COVID-19 AND NOW IT HAS MADE A
MASSIVE COMEBACK.
HE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT IS
THE BIGGEST VIRUS SUPER SPREADER
EVENT, NOT MODERN HISTORY, IN
AMERICAN HISTORY, AND AMERICANS
WILL DIE AS A RESULT OF THESE
POLICIES, AS A DIRECT RESULT.
HE SPENT YOUR MONEY AT RECORD
PACE, LITERALLY ROBBING OUR
FUTURE GENERATIONS.
NOW WE HAVE INFLATION THROUGH
THE ROOF.
HE HALTED THE KEYSTONE XL
PIPELINE'S AND OTHER PIPELINES.
GAS PRICES HAVE NEVER BEEN
HIGHER AND AS A CONSEQUENCE,
EVERYTHING YOU PURCHASE IS GOING
TO COST MORE TO SHIP, AND THAT
MEANS WE ARE GOING TO PAY MORE
FOR EVERYTHING THAT WE ALL BUY.
HE GIFTED PUTIN WITH A NEW
PIPELINE HIMSELF AND GERMANY, BY
THE WAY, THEY MADE A
MULTIBILLION-DOLLAR DEAL WITH
VLADIMIR WHO WAS REWARDED WITH A
SERIES OF CYBERATTACKS AGAINST
THIS COUNTRY?
COMPLIMENTS OF RUSSIAN HACKERS?
THIS IS GREAT FOREIGN POLICY,
MAKE
>> Former President Trump: AND
MAKE RUSSIA RICH AGAIN?
HE BRIBED THE
WHAT DO WE GET AS A RESULT?
HE BOWED DOWN TO THE COMMUNISTS
IN CHINA, NOW THEY ARE
THREATENING TO BLOW UP OUR
MILITARY AND NAVAL BASES,
LECTURING OUR SECRETARY OF STATE
ON HUMAN RIGHTS?
THEY LET HIM GET AWAY WITH THAT?
HE'S NOT ALLOWING CHINA TO TALK
ABOUT REUNIFICATION WITH TAIWAN
IN LESS THAN A YEAR AFTER
CAUSING A WORLDWIDE PANDEMIC?
WITHOUT A DOUBT, JOE BIDEN'S
WEAK MAKE AMERICA LAST PUTTING
US AT RISK AT HOME AND ABROAD
AND IT GETS WORSE.
IN AFGHANISTAN, TOTAL
HUMILIATION.
INSTEAD OF FOLLOWING THROUGH
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP'S GRADUAL
DRAWDOWN OF U.S. FORCES, BIDEN
DEMANDED WE EVACUATE ENTIRELY BY
AUGUST 31ST.
TOLD US THAT A TAKEOVER WAS NOT
INEVITABLE.
HE'S WRONG.
WATCH.
>> IS THE TALIBAN TAKEOVER OF
AFGHANISTAN NOW INEVITABLE?
>> NO, IT IS NOT.
>> WHY?
>> BECAUSE YOU HAVE THE AFGHAN
TROOPS AT 300,000, WELL-EQUIPPED
AS ANY ARMY IN THE WORLD.
AND IN AIR FORCE AGAIN SOMETHING
LIKE 75,000 TALIBAN.
IT'S NOT INEVITABLE.
YOU WILL HAVE NO CHANCE OF
SEEING PEOPLE LIFTED OFF THE
ROOF ON AN EMBASSY OF THE
UNITED STATES FROM AFGHANISTAN.
>> Sean: PER USUAL, JOE BIDEN
WAS DEAD WRONG.
THE TALIBAN MADE TREMENDOUS
GAINS ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
SEIZING PROVINCE AFTER PROVINCE
AFTER PROVINCE AND THEY IN THE
PROCESS WERE ABLE TO COLLECT A
STOCKPILE OF U.S. WEAPONRY AND
MILITARY EQUIPMENT LEFT BEHIND
BY JOE DURING THIS HAPHAZARD
DRAWDOWN.
AND NOW THEY NOW CONTROL 60% OF
THE COUNTRY, JOE, AND EXPERTS
PREDICT THAT COUPLE COULD FALL
IN LESS THAN A MONTH.
THE SITUATION IS SO DIRE, BIDEN
NEEDING TO SEND DOWN 13,000
TROOPS JUST EVACUATE AMERICANS
REMAINING IN KABUL, WHAT'S
RESEMBLING SAIGON, AMERICANS
HASTILY BEING AIRLIFTED OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN JUST AS -- BIDEN
ACTUALLY BEGGING THE TALIBAN,
THIS IS A RADICAL TERRORIST
ORGANIZATION.
HE'S BEGGING THEM TO SPARE OUR
U.S. EMBASSY AND OUR DIPLOMATS
INSIDE WOULD BEGGING THE
TALIBAN?
DOES IT GET ANY MORE HUMILIATING
TO THIS COUNTRY THAN THAT?
THIS IS THE SAME TALIBAN THAT
HARBORED AND ASSISTED, YES,
USAMA BIN LADEN AND AL QAEDA
2001.
THE SAME TALIBAN KILLING
AMERICAN SOLDIERS WERE 20 YEARS,
JOE.
JOE IS BEGGING THESE MONSTERS TO
SPARE OUR EMBASSY?
IS IS NOT PATHETIC AND NAIVE?
YOU'VE GOT CIRCLE BACK JEN PSAKI
TO ENCOURAGE THE TALIBAN TO
CONSIDER THEIR ROLE!
THEY GOT TO CONSIDER THEIR ROLE
IN THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY.
I'M SURE THIS IS THEIR TOP
PRIORITY.
THAT'S A GENIUS COMMENT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE TALIBAN HAS TO MAKE AN
ASSESSMENT OF WHAT THEY WANT
THEIR ROLE TO BE IN THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY.
MAKING CLEAR THAT THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY IS GOING
TO WATCH CLOSELY HOW THE TALIBAN
BEHAVE.
THEY HAVE A RANGE OF TOOLS IN
THEIR ARSENAL AS WELL TO TAKE
STEPS AS THEY SHOULD.
>> DEAR TERRORISTS, WHAT DO YOU
CONSIDER YOUR ROLE TO BE IN THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY?
OKAY, LET ME PAINT THE PICTURE
FOR YOU RIGHT NOW.
AS YOU SPEAK ACCORDING TO THE
REPORTS, TALIBAN FIGHTERS ARE
GOING DOOR TO DOOR AND RAPING
YOUNG GIRLS AS YOUNG AS 12,
SOMETHING THEY'VE DONE IN THE
PAST IN CASE YOU DON'T KNOW ANY
HISTORY.
EXECUTING ANYBODY WHO STANDS IN
THEIR WAY.
ONE 22-YEAR-OLD FEMALE
JOURNALIST IS BEING HUNTED FOR
SPORT BY THE TALIBAN.
SO, JEN, WHAT DO YOU THINK THE
TELE- BOUNDS ROLE IN THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY SHOULD
BE?
ACCORDING TO U.S. OFFICIALS, ITS
ROLE WILL SOON BE A TOP EXPORTER
OF TERRORISM WORLDWIDE ONCE
AGAIN AND ACCORDING TO MARINE
GENERAL FRANK McKENZIE, IT'S
NOT ONLY A MATTER OF TIME BEFORE
AL QAEDA AND ISIS ASSERT
THEMSELVES AND BEGIN TO PLAN
THEIR NEXT ATTACKS AGAINST OUR
HOMELAND.
AND NOW THANKS TO BIDEN'S HASTY
RETREAT, THEY HAVE PLENTY OF
WEAPONS AT THEIR DISPOSAL.
JOE DOES NOT SEEM CONCERNED AT
ALL.
HAD A HARD TIME FINDING THE DOOR
TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
AFTER A TWO DAY WORKWEEK THE
PRESIDENT NOW HAS SUPPORT OF THE
WAREHOUSE FOR ANOTHER VACATION
IN DELAWARE.
WE ARE NOT ENTITLED TO KNOW WHAT
HE DOES.